you know at first I thought I might not
comment on this issue at all everything
that needs to be said about it has
already been said and there wasn't much
that needed to be said in the first
place to be honest but then I realized
that this show carries a certain
responsibility it is my solemn Duty I
believe and I know to single out and
mock the dumbest human beings in the
country in this country uh this this
Duty becomes all the more sacred and all
the more essential when you consider
that the dumbest human beings in the
country are very often the ones running
it human beings like kamila Harris for
example who is a programmed robot with
no authentic opinions or personality of
her own but she's the worst kind of
programmed robot because she's a stupid
one Camilla isn't the focus today but
since we're on the subject I do feel
compelled to mention this video it's a
super cut put together by the Twitter
account RNC research where we see how
Camilla repeats the same line over and
over again and this is uh it's not even
a good line or or a vaguely coherent one
but she really really likes it
uh watch
I can imagine what can be and be
unburdened by what has been you know
what can be unburdened by what has been
what can be
unburdened by what has been what can be
unburdened by what has been what we can
see what we believe can be unburdened by
what has what can be unburdened by what
has been what can be unburdened by what
has been what can be
unburdened by what has been who we can
be
unburdened by who we have been what can
be unburdened by what has been where we
can be unburdened by where we have been
and unburdened by where we are right now
what can be
unburdened by what has been what can be
unburdened by what has been what could
be unburdened by what had been what can
be unburdened by what has been
I don't know if you caught that but
she's saying that we should focus on
what can be
unburdened by what has been I repeat
what can be appear unburdened by what
has been
did you hear that yet it's very
important that you hear that line which
is why Camilla says it to literally
every audience she speaks to and by the
way that Montage goes on for another two
and a half minutes
and and we could even leave aside the
fact that the sentiment she's expressing
is actually incorrect you cannot reach
your full potential or or focus on what
can be if you are as she says unburdened
by what has been that's because you must
carry the burdens of what has been you
must be aware of your past and its
lessons or you'll just repeat what has
been over and over again until you die
but that's not even the point the point
is that someone on Camilla's team told
her this line is brilliantly profound
and amazing and she took that feedback
to heart to such an extent that she
works into every conversation she
probably finds a way to drop that line
when she's like giving her order in the
Starbucks drive-through yeah so hi
normally I get a venti Mocha Cappuccino
but I'm trying today to remain focused
on what can be unburdened by what has
been so I'd like a grande Americana with
cream please thank you
uh what I'm trying to say is that our
country is run by some fantastically
idiotic people and yet even if you were
already aware of that fact and even if
your faith in the intelligence and
competence of the ruling class was
already as low as you thought it could
possibly go
you still were not prepared for this
weekend and The Saga of Congressman
Jamal Bowman and the fire alarm
so just to get you up to speed on
Saturday as you've probably heard by now
Congressman Jamal Bowman pulled a fire
alarm in the house Cannon office
building on Capitol Hill at a time when
the Democrats were trying to delay a
vote on a GOP stop Gap spending bill
uh the fire alarm led to of course an
evacuation a full response by emergency
and law enforcement personnel and we
know that this happened and we know who
was responsible for it because security
cameras caught Bowman pulling the fire
alarm because you're in an office
building on Capitol Hill which means
that they're going to be security
cameras everywhere especially right next
to fire alarms
and uh that means we have embed the
rights you would think and you would
also think that his motivation however
stupid it may have been is pretty
obvious he wanted to delay the vote
like why else would you do that
very very dumb and an open and shut case
you would think
but Jamal Bowman has a different
narrative and it's one that
unsurprisingly the media and his fellow
Democrats were quick to accept without
skepticism accepting it as gospel later
that day Bowman put out this statement
he said quote I want to personally clear
up confusion surrounding today's events
today as I was rushing to make a vote I
came to a door that is usually open for
votes but today would not would not open
I'm embarrassed to admit that I
activated the fire alarm mistakenly
thinking it would open the door I regret
this and sincerely apologize for any
confusion this caused but I want to be
very clear this was not me in any way
trying to delay any vote it was the
exact opposite I was trying to urgently
get to a vote which I ultimately did and
joined my colleagues in a bipartisan
effort to keep our government open I
also met the vote with uh met after the
vote with Sergeant arms and the Capitol
Police at their request and explain what
had happened my hope is that no one will
make more of this than it was I am
working hard every day including today
to do my job to do it well and deliver
for my constituents so
he vigorously denies that he was trying
to disrupt official proceedings of
course he denies it as that would be a
criminal charge an expulsion from
Congress it would be it'd be January 6
all over again an attack on our
democracy an attack on our country worse
than 9 11 in Pearl Harbor combined but
instead he claims that he was perplexed
by the door which was an emergency exit
and he pulled the fire alarm to open it
and several uh media members and other
establishment Figures were quick to
defend him on social media claiming that
the door and the signage around the door
was confusing so just a couple of
examples of this narrative being pushed
should suffice I think here's political
commentator Matt brunig on Twitter
here's where here's what he tweeted
Bowman was trying to walk from the
cannon building to the Capitol Building
to vote unusually the cannon exit he
went to wouldn't open and had this
confusing sign on it he thought it was
saying that you had to press the alarm
to get out this all makes sense what am
I missing
the confusing sign the confusing sign
says this emergency exit only push until
alarm sounds three seconds door uh
unlocks in 30 seconds
that's what the confusing sign says
someone else named Armand dumaluski
commented on the sign saying okay this
sign is genuinely confusing and to that
MSNBC anchor Chris Hayes responded it
sure is exclamation point
and there was a lot of this kind of
thing members of the media proclaiming
that the door and the sign were
downright perplexing just a a mystery
wrapped in an enigma
like looking at that science like trying
to decipher an ancient Egyptian
hieroglyphic it's like it's it's who
knows
now you should know that as Breitbart
reports Bowman actually took down that
sign and threw it to the side then
pulled the alarm and ran the opposite
way to a different door and left so when
the media tells us that his excuse makes
sense they're telling they're telling us
that that is what makes sense it makes
sense that a grown adult man
would walk up to an emergency exit and
in an effort to leave the building tear
down the sign pull the fire alarm and
run the opposite way
this the media says is a sensible
strategy for exiting a building
it makes sense it makes sense that a
grown adult man would react to an
emergency exit that way
after all the sign was confusing
which is which is true I mean the sign
only says that it's an emergency exit
and you need to push down on the door
handle until the alarm sounds this may
mean that it's an emergency exit and you
need to push down on the door handle
until the alarm sounds or it may mean
that you should walk to the opposing
wall and pull the fire alarm and then
run away
maybe that's what it means or it may
mean that you should do cartwheels down
the hallway
or it may mean that you should stand on
your head and sing the 90s hit tub
thumping it may mean anything who's to
say what it means it's impossible to
know the sign is indecipherable
that is if you are illiterate and if
you've never encountered an emergency
exit or a fire alarm before in your life
but almost every adult has which is why
and I think I can say this uh about you
without knowing anything about you
whoever you are watching this
I can say that
in your entire time existing on this
planet
you have never once heard of anyone ever
anywhere
pulling a fire alarm in order to open a
door
you've never considered doing that
yourself you've never done it yourself
you've never heard of anyone doing it or
considering it
you've never been like walking with a
friend down a hallway and come across a
fire alarm
and had your friend turn to you and say
is this what we pressed to open the door
nobody has ever said that to you
nobody has ever asked you that
and if your friend did turn to you and
say that you would look at him in
stunned disbelief
you might actually start to weep as as
his stupidity would be at such a level
that it would be downright tragic to
behold
it it's like it'd be like seeing a grown
man walking around in velcro shoes
because he doesn't know how to tie his
shoelaces it is dumbness so dumb that
you can't even laugh at it it just makes
you sad if anything
well I'll still laugh at it but but
nicer people won't okay we're on the
line with Philip Patrick from Birch gold
what are the greatest uh threats facing
the dollar right now the key to a global
Reserve currency is that it is a solid
store of value well the dollars lost 16
of its buying power since the start of
the pandemic alone so let me ask you
this I have a lot of uh there are a lot
of young young people young families
what's kind of the pitch for them like
why why should they consider this being
a safe haven asset when we see downturns
in the economy it tends to go up the
other thing to consider is just track
record right gold has been around for
centuries it has a proven track record
we understand how gold works with
inflation we understand how gold
typically performs during times of
Market correction but if you're looking
to protect to preserve buying power
that's where gold has the advantage uh
Phillip Patrick we appreciate your time
uh as always and if you want more
information you can text Walsh to 989898
for your free information kit uh Philip
thanks again
and to be clear this is Jamal Bowman's
defense
his defense is that he's a bewildered
dunce who becomes confused and
hysterical at the sight of a door
his defense is that he has the IQ of a
hermit crab
it's a defense so humiliating and so
disqualifying that even if it was true
he'd be better off lying and saying that
it was an intentional criminal act I
mean if that was me and I somehow did
something that stupid
I would lie and say you know what yeah I
was committing a crime put me in jail I
I would rather you all I would rather go
to prison
than have everyone know that I am that
stupid
I would certainly rather be seen as a
clumsy criminal than a guy with a mental
capacity of an amoeba
and here's the thing
whichever is true
either way Jamal Bowman is unfit to
serve
because either he tried to disrupt a
congressional proceeding by staging a
false emergency
or he's an incompetent half-wit who
doesn't know how fire alarms work
I mean it's one of the other
and frankly I don't care which one
though I strongly suspect that maybe
there's a bit of both mixed in
whatever the explanation he should be
kicked out of out of office he is just
another in a large crowd of people in
Washington DC who run our country and
make decisions that deeply impact all of
our lives and yet are both morally and
intellectually bankrupt
these are the kinds of people who always
are there to preside over the collapse
of Empires
people whose moral character is in a
constant game of limbo against their
intelligence
competing over who can sink the lowest
these are leaders
people who can't even open a door
God Bless America
we're gonna need it
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there